biden's border crisis may get fixed but
not by the president
texas governor greg abbott announcing
plans for his state to build
its own border wall without the federal
government's help
homes are being invaded neighborhoods
are dangerous and
people are being threatened on a daily
basis
with guns of people either coming across
the border or those working with those
who are coming across the border in the
federal government's absence
texas is stepping up to get the job done
in florida governor ron desantis sending
his state's law enforcement officials to
help out with the border surge
in texas and arizona this is a disaster
and it is an emergency for people
like texas and arizona they asked all
governors
to be able to send support uh florida's
the first one to answer the call
dana how much of this is politics how
much is real well i think that
i think it's very real especially if
you're in texas and one of the big
frustrations has to be for the governor
that they have this problem the federal
government's not willing to come and
help but
immigration and border security is a
federal government responsibility
so that's why it's pretty amazing that
they would say okay we're going to take
a billion dollars
of state taxpayer money to try to
deal with this problem so i can
understand the governor's frustration on
the political side of things
because of the lack of action by the
biden administration
you are allowing these governors a
chance to shine
abbot is certainly one of them but i
would put doug ducey in that category
certainly ron desantis on many issues
covet related but
also you get to be the first to send
help and christy gnome of south dakota
said i'll be in i'll be there now
all of these people probably do have a
good political future
governors usually do very well if they
want to step up it's usually a better
path to the presidency than ascendancy
but you also have two other border
governors that could be doing something
and could be making a name for
themselves
on this issue but they're not one would
be gavin newsom in california who's
facing a recall effort and the other is
michelle
lujan grisham of new mexico those states
are also dealing with this problem but
their governors are not actually
participating in helping solve it
i wonder if it's effective like they
brought the abbott
brought the border wall back into the
picture effective
if the if the polls start moving against
biden in favor of these red state
governors maybe it actually gets
them off their duffs jesse to do
something i remember when we had a
president that would help the states
remember he sent new york ventilators
and
hospitals god i forget his name
and and now he's hanging texas out to
dry so abbott has to step
up and i like the two things that he's
doing where he's deputizing the state
police to go in and arrest illegals for
trespassing
that's creative and also building up
jail capacity along the border to deal
with the numbers but like dana said it's
hard to for a governor to build a border
wall
because most of that's federal land and
the land that's not federal land is
privately owned so then
you'd have to get all the land owners
that are adjacent to each other to agree
to have a
wall built but so you can get 11
landowners to say yes build the wall and
you get one that doesn't it leaves a big
hole in the wall
but i want to talk about this little
ladies dinner that kamala threw for the
senators
you know how i like perks and if someone
says free dinner i'm there early
and i'll break bread with my enemies you
know the mob did it surely the senate
can do it
but it doesn't leave a good taste in my
mouth when she's out there
triggering a crisis ignoring it cackling
about it unleashing chaos in the state
of texas
and then invites people over for
cocktails and cheese puffs
i wouldn't have gone i would have said
rsvp no thanks maybe later in the year
i'm just not ready for it right now the
holiday party maybe the holiday party
there were three senators who didn't go
female senators
hyde smith lummus and uh cinema
so two republicans and one democrat
would you have gone
i i wasn't were you invited i was not
the soldier
so i the build on the point's been made
i agree more than i disagree on this
this segment here i think one
if the biden administration has not
tightened up a policy here around the
border
uh this could lead to tougher political
consequences and you left out two people
as you were building out you're talking
about how it could help republicans
the two democratic senators in arizona
remember kelly's up for re-election
uh in a year so once the polling data if
and when the polling down i shouldn't
say once if
if the polling data moves wrongly in
that state
i think that's when you'll see the
pressure being placed on on the
president to
to think differently about this you
can't get to the comprehensive aspects
of what i'd like to see us get to around
immigration
including making targeted investments in
some of the countries the vice president
visited
until you deal with the border because
the country
you're not going to find members of
congress democrat mostly republicans are
going to be willing to negotiate and
work with you
unless you handle that first so my
message to the white house is let's deal
with
this border issue in a way that allows
for the messaging to change first then
to get to the root cause issues which
i believe are serious i hope those
around the table do as well but you
can't get to that without border first
but they intentionally broke something
that was fixed and this is how they want
it
yeah but he's right you got to fix the
holes before you you know
work on the rest of the boat real simple
analogy there
look it's interesting i mean uh he got
the you got the texas governor
solving in his way the border crisis
meanwhile kamala
is making making cheese puffs what kind
of message is that it's like
are the dems saying we prefer our female
vice president
to stay in the kitchen oh i mean how
sexist is that think of it but let's let
the men
handle the important things because the
little lady should be in the kitchen
making the cheese puffs think about
think about this comparison in 2024
yeah when desantis what what if desantis
gets the nomination
and joe's out you know wherever and so
she is the choice
and then they come to this issue of
immigration
this is pretty big you know he hit the
ball out of the park she
not only dropped the ball she dropped
the wall
and um i had another idea oh this is
kind of interesting
that line was so good it was like well
thank you i know i just had to ponder
stop while you're ahead no no no
this red state cooperation feels like a
new thing and maybe i'm just too young
to remember
other things that happened like this but
what if this is the start of a trend
of a nation within a nation that is
stepping up to prevent the denigration
of a country that's being kind of like
poisoned by blue state woke-ism
like what if all these states said okay
we got to deal with law and order
we got to deal with uh immigration we
got to deal with all of these things
that are kind of under attack
i'm not saying you know separation but
you're not saying secede
yes you're not saying obviously i'm not
not saying
i'm not saying secede i'm not not saying
i'm saying
uniting together to help save these
incredible values
that are under fire how's that is that i
like it yeah it brings money in those
revenues like more people who flow into
these states the better job they're
doing
texas should build a wall around their
entire state so californians can't
move in and we should yeah or have
people from oregon or how about just
taking a sawzall and sawing off
california and pushing it into the
pacific that's a lot of work though
i still want to see the video of you
playing basketball yes i don't think
they had videos back then
there weren't some grainy polaroids yeah
we'll take this
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else